one thing I do not advise don't get
stoned and rub it all over your body not
a good idea I'm awesome Mon V and these
are the ten essential things that I
can't live without come with me
no keep coming no really keep coming
this way this way look this just we're
going into the void let's go
Oh cuz natural wall here I was born in
Mumbai India I grew up in a city called
Bradford England my best friend was a
cat I was a performer at Walt Disney
World I was in a street improvisational
comedy troupe called sweetness fear I've
been on Broadway what was in Oklahoma
I've been on The Daily Show now for
seven years Jon Stewart has spoken to me
twice they were looking for a brown guy
at that moment John hired me because he
had never seen a brown person before I
have my one charity the aasif Mandvi
charity which is money to me that comes
to me so that I can do things in my life
that I need to do it's surprising how
many things cost money
it's called the man bloomer which is a
good name a creative name like that
that's how it turns on
what you do is you go you go back here
and you groom your back
it is great it's also you know if you
need to go down here also good I use the
Ella Puhi moisture mist this is not only
refreshing when it keeps the wrinkles
away I'll just show you how it works
way too long ah there you go there it is
it's just gorgeous oh and you can just
put it all over you you're just taking
off yes
oh I don't think you're supposed to put
it all over your body but but I do tiger
balm now tiger balm is a cure-all
if basically you can put it on anything
if you have a cold you put it under your
nose it's in like a menthol thing if you
have a headache you put it there don't
put it on your penis this is well no you
can't
you may say awesome why do you have a
picture of Julian well he's very good
reason Julian Lennon was my first
concert that I ever went to even though
in this picture he's much older and
heavier than he was when I went to the
concert this reminds me of that moment I
keep it here and I look at it and and it
reminds me of the mistakes I've made in
life so here it is this is my Japanese
body pillow this was a gift to me from
my mother because she was so sick of me
not getting married I sleep with this
three nights a week and the other two
nights I sleep with that one
you know I just now noticed that she's
completely naked
this is pornographic this is completely
pornographic I had no idea yeah those
are those are things I can't live
without I mean obviously you know this
is not the one that I normally wear this
is a prop that they gave me follow us at
hashtag GQ ten and you can follow me on
Twitter at awesome that's right
plug in much with